it's not like I'm actually gonna murder
somebody on camera are you though Chad
bachelorette villain Chad Johnson made
his debut on bachelor in paradise
Tuesday night and it was violent no no
no no guff no guff offensive I'll throw
you under a bus and hold you down and
uptight
make sure you smell like peppery and
very messy
Chad lost his mind last night and not
only did it lose his mind but he lost
all the contents in his body
apparently he pooped his pants and he
regrets I mean I regret everything that
day but I can't take it back so whatever
way it goes
I spoke with Chad to get his reaction
about everything that happened at least
everyone will know the worst-case
scenario now everyone's gonna know the
worst possible scenario with me and so
I've already gotten out of the way with
the entire world but Chad's also playing
a bit of blame game saying he intended
to show people another side of himself
on the show have fun and then after that
go on dates I didn't know everybody and
I wouldn't exactly granted that
opportunity after the
well what is that kind of on you I mean
maybe I mean everybody kept like you
know I mean yeah I got a little crazy
but everybody kept coming up trying to
grab me so how does he address the
extreme comments that got him sent
packing you know that one arm [ __ ]
honey you're sucking that keep sucking
that fame do you want to make any type
of apology right now what went down yeah
you know I probably said something bad
to lace I think there was a bad word
said nothing was I think I made a joke
about Sarah and I do feel really bad
about that
I'm not here an apology in your chat is
there an apology yeah I am sorry to them
for saying the things that I shouldn't
have said do you want America to forgive
you I mean I if they want to forgive me
they can I don't not like begging for
their forgiveness
that's up to them think up their mind as
to whether you know they did an actual
bad person or something he just says
what uncle sometimes
you